peter ciardo is the foreign minister of
hungary he joins us tonight mr sierra
thanks so much for coming on so i know
that you're a diplomat you speak
diplomatically as you should
but i have to ask hungary's example in
the way that it controls its borders at
very low cost with very straightforward
policies that are effective
why do you suppose other countries
haven't learned that very simple lesson
look first of all
i have to reject the introduction i've
never been a diplomat i happen to be
their boss but i've always been a
politician so it's very easy to me to
speak honestly and directly and not
not diplomatically so thank you very
much for the invitation by the way first
of all i have to express my appreciation
uh to you to show the reality about
hungary that's very very rare we are
usually uh faced uh by the uh
by the lies and the fake news uh
produced by the international liberal
mainstream and your interview your
report about hungary is something
brings fresh air uh to us
regarding your question i can tell you
that
whenever we have meetings of the uh of
the foreign ministers in the european
union and whenever we discuss border
protection migration security related
issues then the foreign ministers
usually send
text messages to me during the debate
that i'm doing good and keep on doing
that and say those things and then i
asked them at the end of the debate so
my dear friends why didn't you
contribute also then they say look you
know back at home there are ngos liberal
media coalition government pressure and
so on and so forth so actually the
reason why i think others cannot
implement a honest policy on migration
is that they feel themselves under
pressure by international liberal
mainstream media ngos and political
alerts but but in hungary we have a
political stability two-third majority
in the parliament so we have the luxury
to say what we think and act accordingly
what's interesting is that that behavior
is such a threat to our foreign policy
establishment hysterical morons with
lifelong history of failure and apple
bomber david farmer people who really
supported
foreign adventures that hurt our country
hate hungary and refer to it reflexively
as a dictatorship which obviously it's
not it's democracy
why do you think it's so threatening to
them this nation of 10 million people in
central europe
look i think why they hate us is that we
are conducting a uh patriotic
christian based policy
the target of ours is to reach the uh to
uh to fulfill the national interest
uh we are conservative
and in the meantime we are successful
so basically our existence
is a danger for them
because what they say is that the only
way to have a progressive successful
political system
is that you have to be extremely liberal
and our existence makes it very clear
that no
this is not the only way to be
progressive to be successful to fulfill
the interest of your nation but our way
the conservative patriotic christian
democratic way
you know
respecting our historic and religious
heritage respecting our values like
family
this brings success also so the reason
why they want us to be beaten on the
next election is that basically one of
the last successful conservative
government would be kicked out from
power and then they could speak about
the fact that oh look liberal mainstream
is the only successful ideology in the
world they see you as a much bigger
threat than china which just tells you
everything they're going to try to
interfere in your election as as you
well know good luck peter ciardo the
foreign minister of the nation of
hungary thanks hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else